all right let's get into coronavirus for
the last few days I've been more and
more concerned that Donald Trump is
utterly and completely unprepared to
deal with the corona virus and it
potentially becoming a pandemic that
will affect the United States as well as
the entire world as of this morning
there are more than a t-1000 coronavirus
cases that we know of and more than
2,700 deaths
yesterday we spoke with a spoke with a
doctor specializing in infect ology
about the trajectory prevention how to
manage something like corona virus the
cases are still mostly centered in China
more recently there's been a pretty
significant uptick in South Korea then
you've got Italy Japan and Iran as of
this morning with a lot of with more
cases than most countries in the u.s. 60
cases as of this morning but there is
every expectation that this is going to
get worse before it gets better and the
presidential administration has a large
role to play in managing the situation
we will talk about preparedness we will
talk about who's in charge we will talk
about firings that will certainly be a
disadvantage to dealing with coronavirus
and even Republican Senator Mitt Romney
is willing to say that the Trump
administration is completely unprepared
for a widely spread coronavirus in the
United States there's a report that Mitt
Romney actually confronted Trump
administration officials at a private
briefing in DC yesterday as Trump has
continued to publicly downplay concerns
say it's under control it's going to go
away when it gets warm we're going to be
fine the stock market's going to be fine
the reality is that this is now a red
alert even Republican Senator John
Kennedy during a hearing made it very
clear that he doesn't believe the Trump
administration is even remotely
competent and prepared on this issue and
when everything is sport to the
president being unprepared for something
like this will lead to deaths I tweeted
earlier today people who say I'm not
into politics if there's any silver
lining about this whole coronavirus
fiasco it is that I hope people who say
I'm not into politics realized that
politics can very quickly become life
and death look at Donald
recent tweets tweeting
self-congratulatory pablum quoting
Gordon Chang on the Laura Ingram show
saying quote us acted on the coronavirus
very very quickly tweeting how great he
is doing at handling it quote CDC and my
administration are doing a great job of
handling coronavirus including the very
early closing of our borders to certain
areas of the world it was opposed by the
Dems too soon but turned out to be the
correct decision Trump is focused on
attacking Democrats making fun of mini
Mike Bloomberg and claiming victory for
things he hasn't done like building the
wall instead of actually dealing with a
deadly contagious disease it's just not
a priority for Trump it's underfunded
Trump has no idea what's going on so we
have a two-fold problem here they are
woefully unprepared but they are also
downplaying it for political reasons
it'll disappear when it gets warm
they've been saying more and more almost
like it works that you know they'd like
the disease is going to melt or
something like that and dr. Bowe Gosch
told us yesterday that this is not
something we can assume that this will
go away when it gets warm in the
northern hemisphere we've already heard
from Harvard epidemiologist mark lipstic
who predicts that coronavirus will
ultimately not be containable and within
the year it's conceivable that up to 70%
of the world population could be
infected now the death rate may never
rise beyond 2% but when that many people
are infected you are going to have many
people die if it gets to that level I'm
not being alarmist I'm showing that even
experts say this could happen if it's
not taken more seriously by all
governments and that includes Trump now
additionally it's important to look at
death rates by age when you do that you
notice that below age 40 the coronavirus
death rate is just 0.2 percent even
between 40 and 49 it's just 0.4 percent
above 50 years of age the death rate
starts to climb and of course if you're
70 or all
or even more acutely eighty or older you
are the most at risk that's the case
with regular flu that's the case with
pneumonia that's the case with a number
of different conditions and I've
actually seen what seemed to me like
horribly macabre arguments that we don't
have to worry about the economy because
the people of working age are not dying
at a high rate from coronavirus so we
don't really have to worry KITT can you
imagine and Donald Trump's ignorant and
the denials are are it's not just a
political game at this point we're
talking about people's lives
and after this short break I want to get
right back into coronavirus and talk
about who Donald Trump is putting in
charge
hints it's Mike Pence who barely
believes in science and then I also
after that want to continue talking
about this because there is a talking
point spreading that Donald Trump fired
his pandemic response team and there are
a bunch of people saying that couldn't
possibly be true could it it is very
true it is not only true that Trump
fired his pandemic response team he also
reduced funding to the CDC and it is all
just bad and we'll get to more of it
after the break make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're at it follow me at David Pakman
real quick I want to tell you about a
YouTube channel called up flip they're
friends of our show you can check them
out by going to david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is down below
underneath the video every week up flip
publishes a new video where you get to
meet an entrepreneur learn about the
business they built see what it's like
to live a day in their shoes in that
business I love learning about small
business owners the steps they took to
become successful that's why I love the
content on up flip you'll get an
exclusive look at some really
fascinating businesses each entrepreneur
has many valuable insights and
strategies to share about how to build
and maintain a successful company I
would highly recommend their two-part
series on lean manufacturing which
itself is a really interesting concept
that's all about sort of minimize
waste maximizing efficiency and up flip
breaks it all down you can get to their
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right below
this video make sure you subscribe to
their channel and click that Bell icon
so you'll be notified when they upload
new videos